salud en directo américa de france a 24
y hoy lunes se celebra el día
internacional del orgasmo femenino es
que durante años este tema de la
sexualidad femenina ha sido un tabú
social pero el feminismo digamos que
llegó marina bienvenida muy buen día
para estar cambiando y rompiendo toda
esta exclusión al derecho a sentir
placer por parte de las mujeres marina
también está relacionada a la salud
sexual y las mujeres y por qué es tan
importante este día que como recordemos
es el día internacional del orgasmo
femenino bueno es un día importante para
las mujeres y para conmemorar la noche
de raúl este origen tiene un origen muy
peculiar se retoma 2016 2006 perdón
cuando un político de una región de
brasil vio un estudio que señalaba que
sólo el 28 por ciento de las mujeres
brasileñas de su región alcanzaban o
habían sentido un orgasmo desde entonces
decidió tratarlo como un tema de sant
salud pública en su país por eso se
conmemora esta fecha el día de hoy para
hablar de orgasmos femeninos nos
acompaña a camila camila barrientos ella
es
chico copi terapeuta sexual y nos va a
hablar de este día camila bienvenida y
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 lo primero que siente las mujeres que
es un orgasmo y cuál es la importancia
del punto g para alcanzar un orgasmo
cuéntanos
bueno mira el orgasmos del punto culmine
o el cúspide del orgasmo
en la experiencia sexual sin embargo
pues se ha hablado mucho sobre realmente
qué es el orgasmo y cómo podemos llegar
a él
y el punto que realmente es un mito en
todo esto del orgasmo el punto es uno de
los puntos erógenos importantes para las
mujeres pero no es el único punto el
punto que no tiene que ver tanto con el
clítoris es una zona que se estimula de
manera interiormente en la parte de la
pared vaginal trasera de la mujer y es
uno de los mitos como tantos que hay del
orgasmo femenino pero no es el único y
hay muchos más orgasmos el del punto
camila muy buenos días gracias por estar
con nosotros esta mañana del lunes aquí
en directo américa de france 24 digamos
que lo que sabemos hasta el momento
también es que estos orgasmos ayudan a
fortalecer la salud cardiovascular
liberando hormonas como la adrenalina
endorfinas oxitocina en el caso de las
mujeres que actúan además como
vasodilatador es permitiendo una mejor
circulación cuáles son los beneficios
además de estos que ya les estaba
mencionando de los orgasmos de en las
mujeres
mira pues se ha comprobado que entre más
orgasmos crece la autoestima el amor
propio
la relación con el iq el cuerpo mismo
incluso hay estudios que nos dejan saber
cómo a mayor orgasmo pero auto producido
por las mujeres que hablamos de auto
tokio masturbación las posibilidades de
por ejemplo caer en un abuso sexual o en
situaciones de abuso son mucho menores
también a nivel físico de salud por
supuesto pues todo lo que nos dispare
las hormonas del bienestar y las
hormonas del placer como algunas que
mencionados ahora nos van a hacer todo
el tiempo volvernos dependientes de esas
hormonas es decir que el cerebro a
buscar más actividades dentro de tu vida
diaria que te vayan a induciendo al
bienestar entonces el órgano siempre que
tengamos orgasmos el cerebro va a querer
volver a la dopamina volver a la
oxitocina y eso quiere decir que vas a
empezar a tener hábitos de bienestar en
tu vida porque eso es lo que hace el
cerebro cuando genera estas hormonas de
la dependencia entonces muy seguramente
vas a ir ejercicio a la comida buena
todo lo que tu cuerpo realmente necesita
para tener una salud buena y balancea
camila y sabemos que la penetración no
es la única vía para alcanzar un orgasmo
qué tipos de orgasmos pueden llegar a
tener en las mujeres
mira yo hablé mucho sobre esto creo que
los tipos de orgasmos son infinitos pero
digamos solamente en la parte genital
porque también hay que decir y realizar
el orgasmo las mujeres no solamente
sentimos orgasmos en la zona genital
también hay otras zonas erógenas que nos
pueden llevar a puntos cúspide de la
excitación pero solamente hablando de la
zona genital tenemos pues el clítoris el
punto g tenemos la uretra que también es
otro punto muy importante para el
orgasmo toda la esponja uretrales donde
sale la eyaculación femenina que también
es un tema que ahora está viniendo a
enseñarnos digamos como nosotras las
mujeres podemos tener otro tipo de datos
con otro tipo de sensaciones también
tenemos en la zona anterior del por
knicks que es una zona que está adelante
del cuello uterino bien profundo dentro
del canal vaginal
el propio cérvix la zona acá que es otro
lado que está atrás del serviu entonces
dentro de solamente la vagina y la vulva
tenemos un montón de puntos en donde
viene estimulados
y con conocimiento de la sexualidad
femenina de cómo las mujeres nos
excitamos de cómo las mujeres llegamos
al orgasmo van a hacer que
definitivamente explota en todas estas
hermanas que nos llegan al al orgasmo y
nos llegan las sensaciones muy
placentera oye camila estabas hablando
de un punto muy importante que me llamó
la atención y es que cuando las mujeres
digamos se conocen más su vagina pues se
tienen una una masturbación digamos
regular pues se caen menos digamos en lo
que son los abusos sexuales en por qué
pasa esto
mira porque durante mucho tiempo las
mujeres el cuerpo de la mujer ha sido un
cuerpo que no ha sido de la mujer misma
ha sido del padre del médico del
sacerdote del marido del novio y
lamentablemente el cuerpo de la mujer se
ha puesto como una posición del hombre o
de lo masculino en la sociedad cuando
las mujeres recuperamos ese poder sí y
entendemos que nuestro cuerpo es propio
que es nuestro primer territorio
habitado derecho y empezamos a auto
auto darnos placer cierto empezamos a
entender que nuestros límites primero
que no necesitamos a nadie para que nos
dar placer y segundo cuáles son nuestros
límites no hay una duda en eso no me
gusta esto sí me gusta esto pongo
límites en esto y entonces voy al placer
mucho más segura de lo que quiero de lo
que no quiero ya no soy como una niña
que va y no sabe nada no que al
contrario tengo un poder una soberanía
sobre mi propio cuerpo
camila y también en el mercado ahora de
los juguetes sexuales está muy enfocado
en las mujeres también como ha ayudado
el feminismo a hacer de la masturbación
femenina que deje de ser un tabú
mira yo soy entre muchas otras que hago
y practico me enfocaba mucho sobre las
técnicas orientales porque en el taoísmo
y el tanto digamos que son unas
corrientes filosóficas que se han
enfocado mucho en el orgasmo femenino y
en la sexualidad femenina
entonces digamos que este este
crecimiento de los juguetes sexuales en
occidente es muy bueno para las mujeres
porque por supuesto deja de tener el el
tabú a todo este tema de la sexualidad
que sin embargo yo pienso que las
mujeres además de los juguetes debemos
usar nuestro propio cuerpo si igual que
además de las fantasías de usted o usar
nuestra propia sensación porque si no
caemos en todo lo que es externo
necesitamos entonces las fantasías la
pornografía los juguetes todo está
afuera cuando regresamos como decía
ahora a nuestra soberanía corporal es
mis manos mi aliento mis besos mi
respiración pueden hacer
todo esto sucede a mí no necesito nada
fuera ni un palo masculino hacia afuera
ningún juguete sexual ni la pornografía
sino que todo esto lo puedo generar yo y
creo que ahí vamos en el camino
realmente recuperar nuestro cuerpo como
dije antes como un primer territorio
habitado en el sin embargo pues que
málaga a directores que estén sucediendo
claro camila y además lamentablemente el
daño que le hace también a nuestra
seguridad a la hora de tener relaciones
sexuales la pornografía y muchas
frustraciones también que derivan de la
pornografía además hay un punto muy
importante 8 de 10 personas con vulva no
llegan al orgasmo cuáles son los errores
más comunes a la hora digamos de
intentar tener un orgasmo digamos que a
lo mejor la mente puede ser es pues
nuestro peor enemigo no enfrascarse en
tener este orgasmo tan deseado e
intentar intentar intentar y pues no
lograrlo como como ayudar además a
aquellas mujeres que no logran tener un
orgasmo es que realmente lo tengan
relajarse digamos este autoconocimiento
también por medio de la masturbación de
conocer su órgano sexual
si mira hay dos temas principales a
igual traten de ser muy breve el primero
es entender que el principal enemigo del
orgasmo de la excitación es el estrés en
nuestro cuerpo funcionando así el estrés
sube las hormonas de la sexualidad bajan
ningún animal y menos los mamíferos van
a tener sexo en el momento en que se
sienten amenazados es decir si tenemos
cortisol adrenalina noradrenalina
nuestro sistema
las posibilidades de que yo llegué a
excitación pase la meseta y llegue a un
orgasmo son bastante bajas entonces eso
primero hay que tenerlo muy en cuenta y
segundo la sexualidad está en general
está muy enfocada a una sexualidad
masculina es una sexualidad rápida una
sexualidad de fricción una sexualidad
que rápidamente se prende y se apaga las
mujeres tenemos otro tipo de sexualidad
las mujeres somos mucho más lentas en
llegar a los puntos más altos y nos
quedamos mucho más en esos puntos altos
y luego nuestra excitación baja de
manera lenta también pero como el
conocimiento de la sexualidad masculina
ha sido mucho más estudiada
científicamente parece ser que las
mujeres queremos ir a los orgasmos de la
manera en que van los hombres y así está
construida especialmente nuestra
sexualidad eso es lo que pasa pues
camila la verdad super interesante muy
buen análisis también pues lo que no
estaba contando de pues lo que tiene que
ver con el orgasmo femenino y también
reivindicar el cuerpo de la mujer es
hacer respetar el cuerpo de la mujer y
pues nada mejor que conocerse ustedes
mismas para pues como lo decía usted
bien poner límites y evitar que otras
personas cometan abuso en el cuerpo de
una mujer camila un placer camila
barrera salcedo si cooperante
psicoterapeuta sexual y gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24 camila
muchas gracias
marina también muchísimas gracias
nosotros de esta manera entonces
llegamos al final de nuestro programa
por el día de hoy nos vemos mañana con
más de directo américa para en segundos
un noticiero aquí en france 24
[Música]